one of the craziest things that's
happened in financial markets in recent
memory is when interest rates went
negative that's right people were
literally having to pay to keep their
money in their bank accounts or
elsewhere now of course we don't know
what the future holds and so one of the
big questions has been will the united
states get negative interest rates on a
nominal basis we already know with
inflation at 8.5 percent that the real
rate of return is negative on most bonds
and other types of financial assets but
the big question is will the interest
rates go negative now what we can see is
in the u.s markets we see investors
quite literally betting on what they
think is going to happen and there's a
very specific data point around the euro
dollar futures that tells us investors
definitely believe over the next couple
of years we are going to get negative
interest rates don't listen to me though
my friend george game has got a great
explanation of it here's a little bit of
his video that explains how this is
happening and what investors believe is
likely to transpire the options market
is predicting the unthinkable what am i
referring to specifically
negative
interest rates and i'm not talking about
real rates i'm talking about negative
nominal rates i want to start by looking
at a chart from the atlanta fed as you
can see this is kind of the line in the
sand from here
the market is expecting the fed to start
cutting interest rates there's an
options market for euro dollar futures
the euro dollar futures basically a bet
on libor was kind of a bet on the fed
funds rate the prices for the options
that would be in the money or the prices
for the options that would pay out if
interest rates actually go negative
have skyrocketed so the smart money in
the options market for euro dollar
futures is actually making big bets
right now
that in the very near future
the fed will take interest rates
negative this is a huge recession
indicator and why would the fed do
something so extreme with interest rates
because at that point in time we would
either be in a recession if not an
economic depression george has always
got great explanations and so it's
really important to pay attention here
is that as soon as you see investors
betting on the next two three four years
that we're going to get negative
interest rates it's worth paying
attention to the idea is that the
central bank will continue to raise
interest rates they're going to put
immense pressure on the economy they're
going to push us into a recession and
the only tools that they have
quantitative easing and the manipulation
of those interest rates when we get to
that recessive period they're gonna
panic they're gonna capitulate and
they're going to have to slam down the
interest rates last time in 2020 was two
emergency rate cuts this time who knows
what they could do how quickly and how
severe and so ultimately if we
eventually broached that negative
interest rates in the united states this
isn't just a mathematical concept it's
not just an economic concept there's
also a religious element to it too
negative interest rates that happens
somewhere else that happens in europe or
developing nations not here in the
united states we have our [ __ ] together
we are in control we don't need to go to
negative interest rates right right well
we're gonna find out but right now
investors are definitely betting on the
fact that they think negative interest
rates are on the way the next couple
years are going to be very interesting
to watch this all play out hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time